It all started in 2008, when Nick Fury told
Tony Stark about the Avengers Initiative,
and ten years after Iron Man hit theaters,
Earth's mightiest heroes are set to face their
toughest challenge: Thanos the Mad Titan.
Directed by Joe and Anthony Russo, Avengers:
Infinity War will feature at least 76 characters,
be Marvel's longest movie to date, and revolve
around six mysterious stones.
Well, seven if you count Deadpool's continuity
gem.
Which they won't.
It's a lot to keep track of.
So if you need a primer to prepare for history's
biggest superhero movie, here's everything
you need to know before seeing Avengers: Infinity
War.
Who is Thanos?
The Mad Titan first appeared in the mid-credits
scene for The Avengers.
Since then, he's popped up a few other times,
but we haven't really gotten to know the guy.
What does he want with Earth's mightiest heroes?
"And who is the man in the purple chair?
He's purple, he has a magic glove, doesn't
like standing up."
In the comics, Thanos is a member of the Eternals,
a race of genetically-engineered superhumans
who colonized Titan, Saturn's largest moon.
Incredibly intelligent, uber-powerful, and
born deformed thanks to a mutant gene, Thanos
is absolutely obsessed with Death…the actual
personification of Death.
Hoping to win her love, Thanos destroys half
the universe with the help of the Infinity
Gems.
We don't know how much of that backstory will
play into the film, but it's clear Thanos
means business, and when he comes to complete
his rock collection, the Mad Titan might teach
the Avengers what it's like to lose.
Alien sidekicks
When Thanos arrives, he'll have plenty of
backup.
The big baddie has a massive extraterrestrial
army, but he's also bringing his very own
evil supergroup: the Black Order.
In the comics, these are Thanos' top generals,
and while there are usually five, it looks
like we're only getting four in the movie.
The Infinity Stones
We know Thanos wants to get his big purple
hands on the Infinity Stones, but what are
they, exactly?
We know a bit about their history, thanks
to The Collector.
"Then the universe exploded into existence,
and the remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots."
As a result, these six stones come equipped
with devastating powers.
Let's break them down.
Officially debuting in Captain America: The
First Avenger, the Space Stone is a blue gem
inside a glowing cube, and it can open portals
across the universe.
And if the Space Stone lives up to its comic
book potential, then Thanos might gain the
ability of omnipresence, or being everywhere
at once.
Then there's the Mind Stone, which powered
Loki's staff in The Avengers.
Although it looks blue there, the Mind Stone
is actually yellow and can hypnotize and manipulate
its victims.
The Power Stone is the purple orb that appeared
in Guardians of the Galaxy.
It enhances its user's strength and can waste
entire planets.
In the comics, it also supercharges the rest
of the stones, making them all more powerful.
Green and stored inside a magical locket,
the Time Stone showed up in Doctor Strange
and grants its user the ability to reverse
time and create time loops.
"Dormammu, I've come to bargain!"
"You cannot do this forever."
"Actually I can."
The most perplexing gem is the Reality Stone.
It debuted in Thor: The Dark World as a sentient
red goo, and while we haven't seen its full
powers yet, in the comics it can be used to
alter the nature of reality itself.
There's one final rock that we haven't seen
yet, an orange gem known as the Soul Stone.
In the comics, this allowed Thanos to control
all living souls and even resurrect deceased
ones.
Where are they?
According to the Infinity War trailers, Thanos
will definitely get the Space Stone and the
Power Stone.
So where are the rest of the Stones?
Doctor Strange placed the Time Stone inside
the magical compound of Kamar-Taj, and following
the events of Thor: The Dark World, the Reality
Stone was given to the Collector.
Though after the explosive events of Guardians
of the Galaxy, who knows if he still has it.
And then there's the Mind Stone, which has
been everywhere.
In Age of Ultron, the Mind Stone ended up
in Vision's forehead, granting him the ability
to fly, shoot lasers, and walk through walls.
As for the Soul Stone, nobody knows where
it's hiding.
There are plenty of theories being kicked
around — maybe Heimdall has it, maybe it
won't show up until Avengers 4… or maybe
Thanos has had it all along.
Torn Avengers
By the end of Captain America: Civil War,
the Avengers were still split.
Captain America has given up the shield and
his star-spangled identity and gone on the
run.
Tony Stark, on the other hand, is still working
with Vision and War Machine, and the Russo
brothers promise Infinity War will grapple
with the results of the last Captain America
movie.
If the Avengers hope to defeat the Earth's
extraterrestrial threat, they'll have to put
personal differences aside.
Guardian grudges
Star-Lord and his band of misfits will finally
meet the Avengers in Infinity War, and really,
this battle against Thanos is far more personal
for the Guardians than it is for the rest
of the heroes.
Nebula and Gamora were "adopted" by Thanos
as kids and turned into super assassins.
Nebula has grown up hating Thanos, and getting
revenge against her stepdad is Nebula's number
one priority.
"I will hunt my father like a dog and I will
tear him apart slowly.
Piece by piece."
Drax the Destroyer is also on the hunt for
Thanos because he had Drax's family slain.
And with her own dark past involving Thanos,
Gamora isn't a big fan of her adoptive father
either.
"When Thanos took my homeworld, he killed
my parents in front of me.
He tortured me, turned me into a weapon."
Seeing Scarlet
Chances are pretty good the Vision won't make
it out of Infinity War alive, considering
Thanos wants the Mind Stone, and it's lodged
squarely in Vision's forehead.
The Scarlet Witch also got her psychic powers
from that particular gem, so maybe that's
why she and Vision get along so well.
There was definitely romantic tension between
the two in Captain America: Civil War, and
that might develop into a full-blown romance
for Infinity War.
Elizabeth Olsen told Nerdist that her Infinity
War performance is her "most emotional arc"
in an Avengers movie.
It's a love affair that lines up with the
comics, and it will be interesting to see
how the two pull off this star-crossed affair,
considering they were on different sides in
Civil War.
Of course, their romance will make it way
more painful if the Black Order rips that
rock out of Vision's head.
First meeting
Thor: Ragnarok saw the Hulk and Thor on a
different path from the rest of the Avengers…and
in a different part of the universe.
And as the film came to an end, things took
a very dark turn.
"Meek, where are you from?"
"Oh, Meek's dead.
Yeah, no, I accidentally stomped on him on
the bridge."
Nope, not that.
In Ragnarok's mid-credits sequence, the Asgardians
were dwarfed by an ominous warship.
MCU producer Kevin Feige confirmed that the
craft is the Sanctuary II, Thanos' flagship.
Chances are good that Thanos will capture
the Asgardian ship — probably to steal the
Space Stone that Loki most likely snatched
from Odin's throne room.
Home front
Wakanda was once thought of as a third-world
country, until it turned out to be super high-tech
thanks to a particular resource.
"I don't follow, what comes out of Wakanda?"
"The strongest metal on Earth."
But why is Wakanda going to play such a pivotal
part in the film?
Well, get ready for minor spoilers.
According to Anthony Russo, the Mind Stone
is going to end up in T'Challa's homeland,
so it makes sense that Thanos and his army
will battle the Avengers and Black Panther's
warriors on the Wakandan plains.
Black Panther has also been protecting Steve
Rogers' best friend, Bucky Barnes, since Captain
America: Civil War.
Until recently, Bucky has been sleeping in
a hibernation chamber, but in a post-credits
scene in Black Panther, the newly armed super
soldier was out and about again.
So when the Wakandans face off against Thanos,
Bucky will be right there with them.
Missing Avengers
Avengers: Infinity War is definitely going
to be crowded, and several of the main heroes
have already been lost in the marketing shuffle.
Spider-Man and Doctor Strange have both shown
up in the film's trailers, but where exactly
are Hawkeye and Ant-Man?
Clint Barton and Scott Lang are pretty big
players in the MCU, but neither have appeared
in the trailers or on the official poster.
So have these two Avengers gone AWOL, or will
they help take on the Mad Titan?
According to the Russo brothers, Hawkeye is
still around, but he's living a different
life than his superhero buddies.
As they explained:
"Hawkeye's on his own journey in this movie.
[…] He has a unique reaction to the civil
war situation that puts him in a special spot
in this film."
As for Ant-Man, Slashfilm reports that he'll
show up in the film, and Paul Rudd is listed
on the cast list.
So maybe the tiniest Avenger is lurking in
the trailers somewhere, but we just can't
spot him.
He could even be inside someone's suit.
"Who's speaking?"
"It's your conscience!
We don't talk a lot these days."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!